you're looking at some street scenes
from the miami book fair international
as the very large crowd gathers here on
the campus of miami-dade college
temperatures in south florida are in the
mid 80s today but that is not dispelling
the crowd in any sense but we're going
to take you from the heat of the miami
campus
to
the inside of the chapman center on the
miami dade campus to hear our next panel
session and let me tell you a little bit
more about it it is a combined
presentation by penn international and
the aclu it's called something to hide
writers and artists against the
surveillance state a long list of
participants including mitchell kaplan
whom you just heard from billy collins
art spiegelman carl hyacin francine pros
esmerelda santiago and nikki giovanni
this panel is expected to last about one
hour live coverage on book tv
a wonderful performance including carl
hiason i understand
who if you were here earlier learned
that he came to the rehearsals with his
guitar teacher
now that may be a lie but
i don't know
i also um this is going to be a long
program i'm not going to talk but
pick up your updated schedule
know that room 3315 is in this building
and not building one
which is a big mistake we made
and
so i'm going to introduce francine pros
who will start the program
[Applause]
thank you all
i'm francine pros president of pen
american center i'd like to welcome you
to something to something to hide
writers against surveillance each of the
readers this afternoon is going to read
a passage from this country and abroad
from the past present and future each of
which has something to do with the
dangers that surveillance poses to
creative freedom
pen american center has been working
very hard against surveillance through
advocacy and litigation and at the
moment we're working in cooperation with
the aclu against the fisa amendments
which our current administration has
recently passed
expanding the rights of the government
to listen into your phone calls and read
your emails so i want to
urge all of you to support penn by
becoming associate members you can fill
out the membership forms which you have
in your packet and
help us and thank you
i'm nikki giovanni
[Music]
65 years ago
speaking of the role of african-american
soldiers speaking of the role
african-american soldiers were playing
in world war ii
langston hughes declared
we know that america is a land of
transition
and we know it is within our power to
help it find further change toward finer
and better democracy than any citizen
has known before
the american negro believes in democracy
we want to make it real
complete
workable not only for ourselves the 15
million dark ones but for all americans
all over the land
at the time he gave that speech hughes
was under surveillance by the fbi for
his leftist political views
not long after
life magazine called hughes paul
roberson and albert einstein
quote dupes and fellow travelers end of
quote
in the 1950s he was subpoenaed to appear
before the house on american activities
committee and the fbi listed him
langston hughes as a security risk
here's his point let america be america
again was published in esquire and in in
the international worker order pamphlet
a new song in 1938
those who monitored his movement and his
words often cited it as a justification
for their surveillance
it reads a little differently this week
[Music]
let america be america again let it be
the dream it used to be let it be the
pioneer on the plane seeking a home
where he himself is free america was
never america to me
let america be the dream the dreamers
dreamed let it be the great strong land
of love
where never kings connive nor tyrants
scheme that any man may be crushed by
one above
it was never america to me
oh let my land be the land where liberty
is crowned with false patriotic wreath
with no false patriotic wreath but
opportunity is real and life is free
equality is in the air we breathe
we breathe there has never been equality
for me nor freedom in this land homeland
of the free
so
who are you that mumbles in the dark and
who are you that draws your veil across
the stars
i am the poor white fooled and pushed
apart
i am the negro bearing slavery scars i
am the red man driven from the land i am
the immigrant clutching the hope i seek
and finding only the same old stupid
plan of dog eat dog of mighty crush the
the weak
i am the young man full of hope and
strength
tangled in the ancient endless chain of
prophet power gain of grab the land of
grab the gold of grab the ways of
satisfying need of work the men of take
the pay of owning everything for only
one's own greed
i am the farmer bondsman to the soil i
am the worker sold to the machine i am
the negro servant to you all
i am the people hunga humble hungry mean
hungry yet today despite the dream
beaten yet today oh pioneers i am the
man who never got ahead the poorest
worker battered through the years
yet
i'm the one who dreamt our basic dream
in the old world while still the surf of
kings who dreamt a dream so strong so
brave so true
that even its mighty daring scene in
every brick and stone and every furrow
turned that's made america the land it
has become
oh i'm the man who sailed those early
seas in search of what i meant to be my
home for i'm the one who left dark
ireland shore and poland's plane and
england's grassy lee and torn from black
africa's strand i came to build a
homeland of the free
the free
who said the free not me
surely not me
the millions on relief today the million
shot down went on strike the millions
who have nothing for our pay for all the
dreams we've dreamed and all the songs
we've sung
and all the hopes we've held and all the
flags we've hung
the millions who have nothing for our
pay
except the dream that's almost dead
today
oh let america be america again the land
that never has been yet and yet must be
the land where every man is free the
land that's mine the poor man's indians
negro me who made america who swept and
blood whose faith and pain whose hand at
the foundry whose plow in the rain must
bring back our mighty dream again
sure
call me an old ugly name you any old
ugly name you choose the steel of
freedom does not sting for those who
like who live like leeches on other
people's lives we must take our back our
land again america oh yes say it plain
america never was america to me and yet
i swear this oath america will be
out of the wreck and ruin of our
gangster death the rape and rot of graft
and stealth and lies we the people must
redeem the land the mines the plants the
rivers the mountains and the selfish
plain and all the stretches these great
green states and make america america
again
[Music]
hi i'm jonathan mahler i'm going to read
from an article that ran in the new york
times on april 14th 1906.
it's fairly self-explanatory
it describes the crude efforts of tsar
nicholas ii to carry out surveillance on
the author maxim gorky
who is in exile at the time
during gorky's visit to new york to
raise money for the bolshevik revolution
it's rich with ironies
not least that unlike known communists
and communist sympathizers during the
cold war
gorky was not only allowed to enter the
united states but was celebrated and
welcomed and that a number of leading
american writers mark twain among them
organized fundraising events for the
cause
activities which would probably today
constitute material support for
terrorism
the headline of the story read
russian secret agent is shadowing gorky
czar's spy crossed on the same boat with
the author
follows him about here
and the story begins
a trusted agent of the russian secret
police is in this city at present
spending his government's money friends
of maxim gorky have learned for the
purpose of organizing an effective
system of espionage on gorky and his two
fellow revolutionists who are here to
raise funds for the cause of the russian
revolutionists
the tsar's spy crossed the atlantic on
the kaiser wilhelm der gross the north
german lloyd steamship that brought
gorky to this country last tuesday
though he is a man who has contrived to
make himself practically indispensable
to the russian government through the
valuable services he has rendered his
extensive knowledge of the
revolutionists and his resourcefulness
and while he ranks high in the secret
political force he came humbly in the
second cabin and under a name different
from that under which he is he was known
on the continent
he has managed to keep his place of
residence in this in this city a secret
thus far
long before gorky landed the russian who
traveled with very light baggage had
managed to get ashore and pass the
custom house officers
he was waiting at the gangway when gorky
came ashore with his wife and his
adopted son and when their carriage
drove away the tsar's spy followed in
another carriage
since then he has been seen occasionally
about the lobby of the hotel bel claire
and is even said to have entered the
apartments of the russian writer as one
in the endless procession of visitors
who come and go every day
it was on wednesday evening that one of
gorky's friends became suspicious of the
russian spy who probably from a sense of
security was led into acts that were
indiscretely bold and communicated his
suspicions to some of the russian
writers other friends in this city
on wednesday afternoon the secret agent
who is described as a man of about 35
of medium height with a florid
complexion and a small blonde mustache
was loitering about the lobby of the
hotel belclair keeping close to a group
of reporters who were waiting to see the
russian author
later in that same day the man turned up
this time with the bland announcement
that he was the correspondent of a
german newspaper at three fifth avenue
the home of the a club where on that
evening mark twain and other american
friends of the russian cause had
gathered to launch the auxiliary
movement in this country
friends of the russian author are at a
loss to understand why the tsar's
government should subject him to any
espionage while in this country
especially as he has made no secret of
the purpose of his coming and as the
newspapers from day to day might be
dependent upon to record the doings of
gorky and the american friends of the
russian revolution
it was pointed out the only good that
the russian government could do by
having gorky and his fellow
revolutionists washed would be to
disclose any effort on their part to
purchase arms in this country and have
them shipped from an american port for
the use of the russian revolutionists
in that case the united states
government if informed would be
compelled to step in and prevent the
shipment
it is likely that if any such attempt
was discovered in the the russian
revolutionists would be expelled from
the united states
but while such a plan may enter into the
schemes of the revolutionists here it is
likely this would be managed in such a
roundabout way that the russian agents
would have no opportunity of discovering
it by dogging the footsteps of the
revolutionists themselves
they are circumspect almost to a fault
as a result of the system of espionage
they have had to contend with in their
own country for many years
gorky himself said yesterday that when
he left europe he was in no sense in
exile
quote but while nominally i am at
liberty to return to russia at any time
i have no doubt that i would be arrested
and cast into prison the moment i set
foot on russian soil especially after my
utterances in the last few days
i shall not let that deter me however
when the moment has come to return we
will go back and brave the danger but
the time has not yet come
the russian author remarked jokingly
that he had already been the tsar's
guest and next-door neighbor so to speak
when he enjoyed his hospitality in the
fortress of saint peter and saint paul
in the russian capital this fortress is
opposite the winter palace thank you
[Applause]
hi i'm carl hiason
[Music]
the freedom of information act or foia
is a magical little piece of legislation
that allows everyday folks like you and
me to access the official files of
agencies like the federal bureau of
investigation the central intelligence
agency the military and other government
departments
foia is not a magic pill the government
often withholds documents or censors the
copies they provide to the public
but the records that people have
received from the u s government offer a
revealing glimpse into the wacky world
of government surveillance and the links
that they will go to to monitor the
private lives of public figures
whether we like to admit it or not we
all have secrets
large or small they are for good reason
our own
writers artists and entertainers believe
it or not have secrets too and like it
or not celebrities generally get
accustomed to the public glare and
tabloid reports watching their every
move
but long before there was tmz and us
weekly
there were the files of the government
and law enforcement agencies maybe the
most salacious paparazzi of them all
i'm going to read selected excerpts from
some of the files of the artists that
were of interest to uncle sam
in 1943 the fbi started investigating
the comedy duo abbott and costello
after a woman contacted the agency to
report they were using quote secret
codes in their tv show
although the fbi decided the informant
had invented this code
they continued to watch the pair because
quote
bud abbott the well-known motion picture
and tv star is a collector of
pornography
and allegedly has 1
500 reels of obscene motion pictures
which he shows in his home where he has
a projector of his own
although abbott is an alleged collector
and there is not an allegation of
interstate transportation of this matter
a case is being opened in this office as
a control file to follow and report to
the bureau information coming to the
attention of this office
in 1951 the fbi filed a memo titled
nat king cole security matter
from internet's quote again from
information furnished to the office in
1945
it appears that coal and censored
were members of the communist party in
the communist political association
during that period probably attached to
the cultural groups in hollywood
what was the terrible communist
organization you might ask
quote
a confidential informant of known
reliability
advised in august 1949 that king cole
was a member of the music division of
the southern california chapter of the
arts
sciences and professions council
1964
the attorney general's office began
receiving complaints that the record
louis louis
by the kingsman contained obscene lyrics
i get to recite some of those for you
the fbi was immediately on the case a
few fbi agents decided to decipher the
hard to understand lyrics themselves
hear and brace yourself
are some of the verses the minds at fbi
headquarters conjured up
i can't do justice to the song without
the music but if you'll remember the
song and who doesn't
here's how it went
according to the fbi fine little girl
waits for me
to get your thrills
across the way girl i dream about is all
alone she could never get away from home
every night and day
i play with my thing
i [ __ ] your girl all kinds of ways
in all night now meet me there i feel
her low i give her hell hey you [ __ ]
hey lover maker now hold my bone it
won't take long
that was version number one from the fbi
another version heard another excuse me
another agent heard these lyrics
she's got a rag on i'll move above it
won't be long she'll slip it off
and yet another agent heard the
following oh louie louie oh no get her
way down low now oh louie louie oh baby
we'll take her and park all alone she's
never a girl i'd lay at home
the fbi went so far as to interrogate
two members of the kingsmen
who swore their lyrics weren't dirty
since there were so many supposed
version of the lyrics floating around
fbi headquarters no charges were ever
brought
the conflict the controversy did however
spark album sales
the real lyrics the real lyrics
louie louie
oh yeah away we go now yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
louie louie
oh baby away we go
a fine little girl she wait for me
me catch the ship
across the sea
i sailed the ship all alone
i never think i'll make it home
louie louie away we go now
those were the real lyrics
yeah well
[Music]
if if dave berry were here he could
supplement with the music
in 1971 the fbi started to receive
complaints about the subversive nature
of the television show laugh in
in an ironic twist the an fbi agent
filed the following report about the
show quote
during captioned show
a skit was performed using various
regular members of the show's cast this
portion was introduced by a shorter skid
representing a president and the first
lady sitting in the white house chatting
between them was a large voss of flowers
when their conversation turned to the
director meaning mr j edgar hoover
it was made obvious that one of the
flowers was actually a bugging device
and the president spoke directly to mr
hoover by means of this device
quote
although as is common practice in this
show jokes and sight gags were made in
rapid fashion emphasis in terms of
subject matter was placed on
surveillance type activities and
clandestine type operations in one minor
skit two agents were portrayed meeting
and being extremely guarded in their
conversation with each other trying to
elicit information from the other
in all all in all the skit pertaining to
the fbi was rather typical of the poor
fare which is served on this so-called
laugh show
tasteless
sometimes downright vicious jokes and a
great deal of forced humor add up to a
more telling commentary on this
low-grade show itself than on the fbi
thank you very much
[Music]
i'm still francine pros
i'm going to read a short selection from
the great cuban writer reynaldo arenas's
novel the color of summer the last of
his five volume cycle of
autobiographical novels
he called these work a secret history of
post-revolutionary cuba and that is what
they are
the color of summer in particular is a
rebel asian celebration of gay life in
cuba in defiance of the extreme
repression and persecution he and his
peers endured
in this selection which is entitled
virgilio pinera reads his evanescent
poems
dozens of uranus's friends gather for a
secret reading by the poe pinera who was
kept under surveillance and repeatedly
jailed and his work was largely banned
by the castro regime i should say that
fidel is referred to as fifo all the way
through this election
barefoot and dressed in a guayabera so
long that it reached all the way to his
angles
virgilio made his entrance
maestro maestro welcome shouted the
queens almost in unison
bring in the brazier was the poet's only
greeting
olga andrejo mahoma and skunk in a funk
hurried out to the kitchen and returned
with a hibachi filled with charcoal
they placed it beside a small table that
the poet was sitting at and immediately
virgilio began he began with a poem he
had written the night before
and his listeners immediately knew that
they were in the presence of greatness
it was a perfect poem containing all the
most secret hidden sadness of every
person
individually and the pain of humanity in
general
while the poet read a magical hush fell
over all those terrified and grotesque
figures
the guest's expression became peaceful
their eyes filled with sweet tears their
bodies took on a repose that terror had
prevented them for feeling for many
years
poetry had taken the listeners to
another realm
a place that no longer existed almost
anywhere much less there on that island
accursed and at the mercy of fifo's
insane and often cruel capricis
but then alas virgilio's reading of the
palm ended and before the applause broke
out before the spell was broken
he had tossed it into the flames of the
hibachi
a gasp of horror escaped all those who
heard the poem
maestro what are you doing cried
sakuntala lamala tearing at her wig
while anton arfada stuck his hands in
the flames to try and rescue the poem
but mahoma and skunk in a funk obeying a
sign from virgilio stopped the queen and
even slapped her a couple of times
virgilio then spoke
yes cry shout kick
pull your hair or your toupees but heed
me my friends these poems are the
originals not copies and tonight as i
read them i shall burn them
maestro for heaven's sake think of us
how can you deprive us of that beauty
exclaimed ooglies ooglissama
i shall burn them all
but first i shall give you the
opportunity to enjoy them myself the
opportunity to read them
one writes for others there is no doubt
of that
and all writing is revenge to that rule
there can be no exception
thus i write my revenge and then i'm
obliged to read it if i didn't it would
be as though it had never existed
but immediately afterward i must burn
what i've read
i can leave no proof of my revenge for
if i did then a greater revenge fifo's
revenge would swoop down and annihilate
me
resign yourself to hearing these poems
one time
and one time only as i have resigned
myself to my own fate which is yet more
terrible the fate of having to write
them read them but once and consign them
forever to the flames
at that
the poet put on his thick glasses
picked up another sheet of paper and
began to read
instantly his audience was again
transformed
this time the room was filled with
angels slenderness teenagers with the
faces and bodies of demigods and all
enthrall to the music of a true god
when he had finished reading virgilio
raised the poem and addressed his
audience
i repeat there are no copies this is the
original
once i fling it into the flames it will
be gone forever
and so saying the poet flung the
manuscript into the flames
a whale of horror filled the apartment
so loud were the protests of disbelief
and pain that olga andreas turned on the
lights and begged them to control their
grief since otherwise the watchdog
committee for her block might hear them
and then in the face of a possibility of
a search for gilio would have to burn
his poems
before he had read them
what we might do
is gag those who can't control
themselves suggested virgilio who is
terrified that the watchdog committee
might knock at the door
raise your hand if you want to be gagged
and everyone even olga andrea herself
raised a hand
the hostess decided to sacrifice one of
the few bed sheets she had left
and she skunked in a funk in bahama tied
a gag on everyone in the living room
then virgilio continued his reading
now
they were seeing thousands of indians
massacred
they saw millions of black men and women
enslaved and thousands of runaways
hunted down with dogs
and now they saw millions of all races
enslaved and constantly monitored but
somehow managing to elude the
surveillance and throw themselves into
the sea
to gnaw away at the base of the island
and they saw themselves under the ocean
gnawing desperately while armies of
sharks led by one huge and particularly
bloodthirsty specimen bore down on them
to devour them
and then at last they saw the country
and the counter country because every
country like all things in this world
has its contrary its counter country
forces of darkness to work to ensure
that only superficiality and horror
endure that all things noble beautiful
brave and life enhancing the true
country
disappear
the counter country the poem somehow
revealed this is monolithic rigid
vulgar
the country is all that is diverse
luminous mysterious
and festive
and this revelation
more than the images of all the
beautiful things they had seen
invested the listeners with an identity
and a faith
and they realized that they were not
alone
because beyond all the horror
including that horror that they
themselves exuded
there existed the sheltering presence of
a tradition
formed of beauty and rebelliousness
a true country
we have in puerto rico a long history of
literary resistance our poets writers
and journalists challenge authority
using their words
this year in puerto rico we commemorate
the 100th anniversary of birthday of
juan antonio correa
who dedicated his life to the struggle
for puerto rican independence he was
jailed numerous times for speaking his
nationalist believes but his voice was
never slice silenced
quoting jose de diego one of his mentors
coren hair often said
loosely translated we must sing about
our country so that we can defend it he
believes that poets have a mandate to
write the unspeakable
i have chosen two poems by kored i will
be speaking reading them in spanish with
no translation
the first is pictographia in which the
poet sees the history of our puerto
rican people carved on a pre-columbian
stone
callia un sol todo borinquen sobr mi
frente des cubierta
jourquez
[Music]
[Music]
the second poem has been set to music by
roy brown i believe and might be
familiar to some of you present you are
fortunate to have heard it by lucas
benitez and others and even luckier that
i will not attempt to sing it
it is obao moin
[Music]
[Applause]
hi i'm mitchell kaplan thank you
you know i usually stand up here in
front of you as one of the organizers of
the fair but this afternoon i stand in
front of you as one of the participants
and i just want to tell you how well
organized this fair is
wonderfully done
uh i also want to let you know that
after art spiegelman reads we're really
really pleased that we're going to be
have billy collins will come up here and
read as well so that's a special treat
those of you who saw the reading last
night you know how how wonderful billy
collins is
this afternoon i'm going to read an
excerpt from freedom to write a lecture
of the turkish nobel laureate oran
pamook delivered as part of penn's world
voices festival of international
literature in 2006.
in it he describes serving as a guide
for arthur miller and harold pinter when
the two men traveled to turkey in 1985
on a pinned delegation to protest the
imprisonment and persecution of writers
in that country
who later faced prison himself and who
we now know came close to being
assassinated
by right-wing extremists a couple of
years ago
spoke of what it is like to create under
such severe restrictions and pressure
so let me tell another story that might
cast some light on the shame and pride i
felt 20 years ago while i was taking
miller and pinter around istanbul
in the 10 years following their visit a
series of coincidences fed by good
intentions anger guilt and personal
animosities led to my making a series of
public statements on freedom of
expression that bore no relation to my
novels
and before long i had taken on a
political persona far more powerful than
i had ever intended
it was at about this time that the
indian author of a united nations report
on freedom of expression in my part of
the world an elderly gentleman came to
istanbul and looked me up
as it happened we too met at the hilton
hotel
no sooner had we sat down at a table
then the indian gentleman asked me a
question
that still echoes strangely in my mind
mr pamook
what is there going on in your what is
there going on in your country that you
would like to explore in your novels but
shy away from due to legal prohibitions
there followed a long silence
thrown by his question i thought and
thought and thought i plunged into an
anguished dostoevsky in
self-interrogation
clearly what the gentleman from the u n
wished to ask was
given your country's taboos legal
prohibitions and oppressive policies
what is going unsaid
but because he had out of a desire to be
polite perhaps asked the eager young
writer sitting across from him to
consider the question in terms of his
own novels i in my inexperience took his
question literally
in the turkey of 10 years ago there were
many more subjects kept closed by laws
and oppressive state policies than there
are today but as i went through them one
by one i could find none that i wish to
explore in my novels
but i knew nonetheless that if i said
there is nothing i wish to write in my
novels that i am not able to discuss i'd
be giving the wrong impression for i'd
already begun to speak often and openly
about all these dangerous subjects
outside my novels
moreover didn't i often and angrily
fantasize about raising these subjects
in my novels just because they happen to
be forbidden
as i thought all this through i was at
once ashamed of my silence and
reconfirmed in my belief that freedom of
expression has its roots in pride
and is in essence
an expression of human dignity
i have personally known writers who have
chosen to raise forbidden topics purely
because they were forbidden
i think i'm no different
because when another writer in another
house is not free no writer is free
this indeed is the spirit that informs
the solidarity felt by pen
by writers all over the world
sometimes my friends rightly tell me or
someone else
you shouldn't have put it quite like
that if only you had worked it like this
in a way that no one would find
offensive you wouldn't be in so much
trouble now
but to change one's words and package
them in a way that will be acceptable to
everyone in a repressed culture and to
become skilled in this arena is a bit
like smuggling forbidden goods through
customs
and as such it's shaming and degrading
i have related all these stories to
illustrate a single truth
that the joy of freely saying whatever
we want to say is inextricably linked
with human dignity
so let us now ask ourselves how
reasonable it is to denigrate cultures
and religions or more to the point to
mercilessly bomb countries in the name
of democracy and freedom of thought
my part of the world is not more
democratic after all these killings
in the war against iraq the
tyrannization and heartless murder of
almost a hundred thousand people has
brought neither peace nor democracy
to the contrary it has served to ignite
nationalist and anti-western anger
things have become a great deal more
difficult for the small minority who are
struggling for democracy and secularism
in the middle east
the savage cruel war is the shame of
america and the west
organizations like penn and writers like
harold pinter and arthur miller are its
pride thank you
i'm annie sundberg and i will read a
passage from the novel the assignment by
swiss playwright friedrich duran mott it
was published in german originally in
1986.
in the assignment nothing is what it
seems otto von lambert a well-known
psychiatrist gives f
a filmmaker
the assignment to follow the trail of
his late wife tina and learn why and how
she was murdered in an unidentified
middle eastern country her raped body
thrown to the jackals at the base of a
mysterious shiite shrine
f accepts because she's mesmerized by
tina's journal which is filled with
hatred for her husband and intensified
by a charged note i am being watched
and
i'm reading sort of a
little bit of a trimmed section of the
passage here
a very suitable definition of
contemporary man might be that he is man
under observation
observation by the state for one with
more and more sophisticated methods
while man makes more and more desperate
attempts to escape being observed which
in turn renders man increasingly suspect
in the eyes of the state and the state
even more suspect in the eyes of man
similarly each state observes and feels
observed by all the other states and man
on another plane is busy observing
nature as never before inventing more
and more subtle instruments for this
purpose cameras telescopes stereoscopes
radio telescopes x-ray telescopes
microscopes synchrotrons satellites
space probes computers
all designed to coax more and more new
observations of our nature
from quasars trillions of light years
away to particles billionth of a
millimeter in diameter to the discovery
that electromagnetic rays are nothing
but radiant mass and mass
is frozen electromagnetic radiation
never before had man observed nature so
closely that she stood virtually naked
before him denuded of all of her secrets
exploited her resources squandered
a logical conclusion always depends on
the initial situation if in his house in
the mountains
he was being observed less and less
so rarely that when he pointed his
mirror telescope at people who he
presumed were observing him from the
cliff they turned out to be observing
not him but something else through their
field glasses
chamois or mountain climbers or whatnot
this state of not being observed would
begin to torment him after a while much
more than the knowledge of being
observed had bothered him earlier so he
would he would virtually yearn for those
rocks to be thrown at his house
not being watched would make him feel
not worth noticing
would make him feel disrespected
being disrespected would make him feel
insignificant
being insignificant would make him feel
meaningless
and he imagined the end result might be
a hopeless
depression
the intellect too he said was incapable
of coming up with a persuasive illusion
of meaning outside of man for everything
that could be thought or done logic
metaphysics mathematics natural law art
music poetry
was given its meaning by man and without
man it sank back into the realm of the
unimagined and the unconceived
and hence into meaninglessness
and a great deal of what was happening
today became understandable if one
pursued this line of reasoning
man was staggering along in the mad hope
of somehow finding someone to be
observed by somewhere by conducting an
arms race for instance for of course the
powers engaged in an arms race were
forced to observe one another which was
why they basically hoped to be able to
keep up the arms race forever so that
they would have to observe one another
forever since without an arms race the
contending powers would sink into
insignificance
but if by some mishap the arms race
should set off the nuclear fireworks
which have been quite capable of
accomplishing for some time it would
represent nothing more than a
meaningless manifestation of the fact
that the earth had once been inhabited
a fireworks without anyone to observe it
without any chance of communicating to
the one who so badly desired to be
observed since he would no longer exist
that in fact he had been observed and
even the religious and political
fundamentalism that was breaking out or
persisting where everyone looked it was
an indication that many indeed most
people could not stand themselves if
they were not observed by someone
and they would flee either into the
fantasy of a personal god or into an
equally metaphysically conceived
political party
that or who would observe them a
condition from which they in turn would
derive the right to observe whether the
world was heeding the laws of the
all-observing god or party
except for the terrorists
their case was a bit more complex their
goal being not an observed but an
unobserved child's paradise
but because they experienced the world
in which they lived as a prison where
they were not only unjustly locked up
but were left unattended and unobserved
in one of the dungeons they desperately
sought to force themselves on the
attention of their guards and thus step
out of their unobserved condition into
the limelight of public notice which
however they could achieve only
paradoxically by drawing back into
unobserved obscurity again and again
from the dungeon into the dungeon
unable even to come out and be free and
short humanity was about to return to
its swaddling clothes
fundamentalists idealists moralists and
political christers were doing their
utmost to saddle unobserved humanity
with the blessings of being observed
and therefore with meaning for man in
the final analysis was a pedent who
couldn't get by without meeting and was
therefore willing to put up with
anything except the freedom not to give
a damn about meaning
so perhaps one could read i am being
observed as a statement of certainty
about victoria's outcome but if one
accepted this possibility
it would just be the beginning of the
actual tragedy
hi
um i'm art spiegelman i'm going to read
a very kind of
unfortunately collapsed version of a
wonderful story by george saunders
called my flamboyant grandson it's in a
collection called in persuasion nation
but i discovered it when i was asked to
illustrate it for the new yorker said i
don't illustrate other people's stuff
but at the point that i read the story
fell in love with this author uh who
manages to catch america's wide-eyed and
renewable innocence while keeping very
clear eye on its horrors and excesses
so this is like i say it's a collapsed
version to give you the shape of the
story but wonderful passages had to be
left out and i hope george forgives me
i had brought my grandson to new york to
see a show because what is he always
doing up here in oneonta singing and
dancing sometimes to my old show tune
records but more often than not to his
favorite cd babar sings sometimes even
making up his own steps which i do not
mind or rather i try not to mind it
although i admit that once coming into
his room and finding him wearing a pink
boa while singing in the voice of the
old lady i have never met a man like
that elephant i had to walk out and give
it some deep thought and prayer
then one day i had a revelation if the
lad likes to sing and dance i thought
why not expose them to the finest
singing and dancing there is so i called
1-800 culture got our promissory voucher
in the mail and on teddy's birthday we
took a train down to new york
as we entered the magnificent lobby of
the eisner theater i was in good spirits
saying to teddy the size of this stage
will make that little stage i built you
behind the garage look pathetic when
suddenly we were stopped by a stern
young fellow a mr ernesti i believe who
said we're sorry sir but you cannot be
admitted on merely a promissory voucher
are you kidding us you must take your
voucher and your proof of purchases from
at least six of our major artistic
sponsors such as aol such as coke and go
at once to the redemption center on 44th
and broadway to get your real actual
tickets and please do not be late as
late commerce cannot be admitted due to
special effects which will occur early
and which require total darkness in
order to simulate the african jungle at
night
well this was news to me but i was not
about to disappoint the boy
we left the eisner and started up
broadway the everly readers in the
sidewalk reading the everly strips in
our shoes the building mounted mini
screens at eye level showing images
reflective of the personal preferences
that we've stated on our monthly everly
preference worksheets the numerous cybec
sudden emergent screens out thrusting or
down thrusting inches from our faces and
in addition i could see very clearly
i could very clearly hear the sound only
messages being beamed to me and me alone
via various cachio oral focusers such as
one that shouted out to me between 42nd
and 43rd mr petrillo you chose burger
king eight times last fiscal year but
only two times thus far this fiscal year
please do not forsake us now there's a
store one block north and the voice of
broadway star elaine weston while at
43rd a light pole mounted focuser
shouted golly leonard remember your
childhood on that farm in oneonta why
not reclaim those roots with a starbucks
country roast
said in a
celebrity rural voice i could not
identify possibly buck owens and then
best of all in the doorway of plc
electronics a life-size gene kelly
hologram suddenly appeared tap dancing
saying leonard my data indicates you're
a bit of an old-timer like myself gosh
in our day life was simpler wasn't it
leonard why not come in and let frankie
z explain the latest gizmos and he
looked so real i called out to teddy
teddy look there gene kelly remember i
mentioned them to you as one of the
all-time great dancers but teddy of
course did not see gene kelly gene kelly
not being one of his preferences
but instead saw his hero babar swinging
a small monkey on his trunk while saying
that his data indicated that teddy did
not yet own a nintendo so that was fun
that was very
very new york but what was not so fun
was by the time we got through the line
at the redemption center it was 10
minutes till showtime and my feet had
swollen up the way they do shortly
before they begin spontaneously bleeding
which they've done ever since a winter
event in the freezing muck of cho by
korea it is something i've learned to
live with if i can sit that's helpful if
i can lean against something also good
best of all if i can take my shoes off
which i did leaning against a wall and
off we went me hobbling teddy holding my
arm making decent time and i think we
would have made the curtain except
suddenly there appeared a citizen helper
who asked were we from out of town and
was that why via removing my shoes i had
caused my everly strips to be rendered
inoperative
and i said yes yes i regretted this very
much
and then i made a mistake i brought out
a 20 and leaning over said look please
the kid really wants to see this show
which is when he pulled out his pad and
began to write so i made a quick
decision and seized that citizen
helper's ticket pad and flung it in the
street shouting a teddy run run
this to me is not america what america
is to me is a guy doesn't want to buy
you let him not buy your respect is not
buying a guy has a crazy notion
different from your crazy notion you pet
him on the back and say hey pal nice
crazy notion let's go have a beer
america to me should be shouting all the
time a bunch of shouting voices most of
them wrong most of them nuts but please
not just one droning glamorous
reasonable voice
as for teddy as i write this it is
nearly midnight and he's tapping in the
room above he looks like a bird our boy
he watches the same musical 15 times in
a row
walking through the mall he suddenly
emits a random line of dialogue and
lunges off to the side doing a dance
step that resembles a stumble spilling
his drink plowing into a group of
incredulous snickering oneontens he
looks like no one else acts like no one
else his clothes are increasingly like
plumage late at night he choreographs
using plastic army men he fits no mold
and has no friends but i believe in my
heart that someday something beautiful
may come from him thank you
[Music]
i'm billy collins i'm going to read a
poem selfishly enough that i wrote
and i want to thank the organizers for
making room for me
it's on the subject of censorship which
is clearly a cousin of surveillance
you don't need to be equipped with a
extraordinary
dystopian imagination to realize that
it's what surveillance
leads to
either censorship
imposed from without
by a government
or more subtly and perhaps
more perniciously imposed
self-imposed
out of a fear that's engendered by the
surveillance
is the title is rain
sometime after the books had been
forbidden
the one about the woman and her daughter
the one about the boy who spoke poorly
and after the smoke from the
incinerators had cleared
it was suggested that censorship be
extended to the plover the wild turkey
and the common moorhen
but these birds have done nothing a few
protested
that is precisely the problem
the loudspeakers answered
it rained that month day and night
men with nets fanned out into the fields
and shouted to each other along the
shorelines
teachers disappeared on the way to their
cars
then the committee came after the
morning glory
for it suggested furling and unfurling
and the ligustrum and the alstromeria
because they were difficult to pronounce
and spell
and then the pine tree for its tricky
needles and cones and parsley and red
and yellow peppers for no reason at all
you would think the lock and the gate
would be safe
but that was well before whispering
shaking hands on the street and hooking
an arm around someone's waist became
subjects of discussion
across long marble tables behind dark
glass doors
and the rain was constant and cold
fine days to curl up with a good book
someone joked but there were no more
books just the curling up of people
quietly in corners and doorways bits of
straw floating down the streets along
the curbs into the turbulent rivers and
out to sea
thank you
hello
hello
how you doing
uh i'm seiku this is steve connell hello
and uh we are presenting a piece that we
uh wrote for a series of poems that we
did for the aclu on their unabridged
website this species called uh monstro
mangas yes and we're very happy thank
you thanks to aclu and penn for having
us here and sad that the conditions
exist that require it
just an ordinary
bright
sunny day
the birds chirp merrily the power lines
the steady thwacketer thwacketta
thwackater of a jump rope can be heard
it's easy to believe you're saying
you're not
there is a monster in our midst
and we know it
we can smell it the faint subtle scent
of something slightly askew trickles of
blood on the driveway tricycle wheels
spinning overturned on the lawn
calm is not an option
this beast came to kill we fed it our
fear we taught it our will but it's
proven harder to keep chained than it
was to build it has electronic ears
listening through walls and floors laser
lenses that watch us in buildings and
stores infrared retinas that peek
through our doors photographic eyes a
million and more that dangle from street
corners peer out from a million sockets
can check the id in the wallet in your
pockets in every home or any block it's
easy to tell if you're guilty or not and
if you're not you shouldn't mind because
this doesn't waste the time there unless
it looks into your mind and spies the
crime there it knows
the steel chains put in place to make
sure we stay safe have been rusted into
red tape that's too easy to break
weakened
by fear-based legislation that cheapens
the constitutions with alterations that
are helping the monster achieve
liberation as long as it is not free we
are if it gets free we aren't and what
happens then
you better get used to wars without end
be careful what you tell your friend
about what you truly think of the
president it should be evident by now it
doesn't matter if it's a private line
privacy has been redefined you'll find
friends don't act like they used to once
your best friend is screwed you tell me
what you do when worried about who you
can choose to be true to when
governments can abuse you if you refuse
to tell them the truth
and i don't know how long we can keep it
changed once it's gained access to all
our information since it has eyes on the
whole nation once it knows when we move
and with who once it knows everything we
do
it'll have too much power to fight
against and its greatest defense it's
mind control makes us think this makes
sense
it doesn't
and we know it
we can smell it
the growing
sordid scent of something terribly askew
trickles of blood on the driveway the
birds chirp merrily a figure on the
ceiling the power lines hum the
inexplicable awareness that we
are being
watched
it's easy to believe we're safe
we're
not thank you
thank you thank you very much
hello everyone
they're a tough act to follow my name is
melissa goodman i'm an attorney with the
aclu's national security project i just
wanted to say a few quick words before
we go but before i do can we have some
applause for all of our fantastic
leaders today
and i just wanted to say a few words
about where we are now on surveillance
and how you can get involved the program
and the fact sheet that we gave you when
you came in provides provides you with
lots of details about the government's
many surveillance tools it also directs
you to websites where you can learn more
sign up for our action alerts and become
a member of both aclu and penn it's
truly important that you get involved
and that you stay involved
obviously we have we're about to have a
new president and a new congress but
these surveillance probably yeah we
could give that a clause
it's certainly worthy of applause
but
with that said these surveillance
problems run deep they run truly deep
and there may not be a tremendous amount
of political will to fix them without a
steady source of pressure from folks
like us and i think that if we've
learned anything from the bush years
it's that we can't get lazy
we have to hold our elected leaders
accountable every single day even the
good ones so we have to remember that
this year just to be on the lookout
we'll be fighting to end illegal
surveillance programs and to regain the
rights to privacy and free speech that
we've lost over the last seven years i
will also be pushing congress to uncover
the full scope of the bush
administration's illegal surveillance
activities quite sadly
we still only really know the tip of the
iceberg and it's truly important that we
remain vigilant in uncovering that so be
on the lookout for that be on the
lookout for new debates about the
patriot act warrantless wiretapping the
monitoring of political protesters and
data mining and of course we at the aclu
and also penn who's a client in many of
our cases will continue our many court
cases challenging illegal surveillance
laws including the fisa amendments act
of 2008 which is the recent wiretapping
law congress passed and also our
challenge to the patriot act national
security letter statute so that's what
we're up to so please join us we really
need your help and we really need your
energies and thank you for spending the
afternoon with us
we would thanks to thank the aclu and
the pen american center for presenting
this fabulous program this is the
[Music]
brochure or
that you may have been given when you
came in look for one take it home pick
it up off the floor the authors will not
be autographing after this session
and our next session will begin
shortly
[Music]
[Music]
you're watching book tv's live coverage
on this saturday afternoon in november
of the miami book fair 2008
the panel
starting next in that room will begin in
about 15 minutes and we're going to use
some of that time in between for your
phone calls 202 585 380 if you're living
in the eastern or central time zones
202-585-3886
and the mountain of pacific time
zones going to show you a short taped
event and then we'll be back to take
your calls
[Music]